oo oo o it's
Halloween Halloween across the spoiler
verse you guys are back we're here with
another podcast we're one day late why
is that because Paul was at a wedding at
the weekend and he got two drunk and he
woke up Monday morning and he was like I
cannot make it through the day H I
managed to pull myself together get some
videos done but by the time the podcast
rolls around I'm just completely dead
anyway as it is H so yeah just that on
top of hand over I thought go we just
push it back push it back one day the
the listeners they love it they love
getting surprises um so yeah sorry guys
we we missed out a whole day and we were
also kind of hoping that the strikes
might have ended but unfortunately that
has not come to pass however it is
Halloween happy Halloween listeners how
are you doing Greg I'm doing good man
you reminded me it was Halloween today I
mean this is this is coming out the day
after Halloween well but what how do you
explain the mask you're
wearing
you got me you got me Paul you got me
what makes you clever yeah I'm good man
I'm good are you kids dressing up yeah
so we've been trick-or-treating with
them um went to the neighbor's house and
then went to another house that had
decorations outside there might have
been decorations it might just have been
a [__] hole but it looked like they'd at
least style their Garden to look
Halloween is but I've had a pretty
pretty wild weekend so for months and
months and months um my wife's been
saying the people's whose wedding we
went to she's like oh the groom his
brother's a YouTuber and I was like oh
whatever you've I'm sure you've heard it
yourself Greg you instantly start
thinking 200 subscribers guy he's gonna
be at the wedding he's gonna be like how
do I add tags and get more views and I'm
like I don't know I don't know how I've
got views myself mate you just have to
figure it out anyway get to the wedding
um I go see the groom Cameron and he's
like oh yeah come come meet my brother
he's doing YouTube and he and I was like
oh whatever yeah let's go see them
because I didn't know anyone there um
because my wife was a bridesmaid and she
hadn't arrived there so I'm sound like a
bit of a dick sound like I shut everyone
down I promise I'm more friendly like in
real life but um go over it's bloody
David from watch Mojo I like whoa whoa
he's probably been feeling for the whole
like last year like he's been getting
told oh kti's husband's a YouTuber and I
bet he's thinking oh he's a [__] and
then I show up he's like yep knew it he
was the biggest [__] in the world
but lovely lovely speaking to the guy um
it was like a watch Mojo heavy spoilers
collab talked loads of [__] about you
mate did you go like Hey how do I get
more views what tags do I need to use to
get more
views yeah exactly that was it and he I
could tell you switched off straight
away and he was thinking oh God I hate
it but yeah lovely seeing the guy so
that was a bit of a weird thing um but
yeah very excited to see him and very
excited to to jump into the podcast
because I'm sure he's listening I'm sure
he's watching he's a big fan now um but
yeah we've got lots of things to talk
about we've got the SAG after strike to
go over more delays um the box office of
the weekend South Park the SP the South
Park the panda verse special some issues
with Marvels the Marvels itself and the
Echo trailer apparently releasing on
Friday and we're going to top it off
with some positivity Invincible season 2
part one review which I've seen very
lucky to check that all out interviewed
the sh enough for it I'm in the big
leagues now hanging out with watch Mojo
and interviewing the show Runners so
yeah Greg would you like to start off
the the SAG strike update would I like
to start off I appreciate you throwing
that to me uh yeah we got a sag after
strike update Paul what's going on okay
so the major Studios um last week they
basically threatened to Hal talks until
January um if if a deal wasn't reached
this week um which was a tactic that
they used with the wga um and we know
how that turned out and then the studio
CEOs reportedly suggested that certain
TV shows would be cancelled if the
strike
continues and basically the strike's
only continuing because of how how much
they're kind of going back and forth and
dragging this whole thing out um but
then they they've came to the table you
know they haven't reached a deal yet
apparently you know what sag of said is
that significant steps still need to be
made before taking you know the deal to
completion um and the big hurdles at the
moment are said to be the use of AI and
also the residuals so yeah how you how
you feeling about how things are
progressing uh are they progressing are
they actually progressing because I
don't feel like a progress I mean it
seems like we're closing in on a gap
here at least I wonder what they're
going to be giving up you know sag is
going to ultimately give into in order
to make sure they can have some
compromise that's what I'm most curious
about because like you can feel you can
feel the need to get back back to work
you know uh obviously the studios want
them to get back to work the actors of
course would like to get back to work I
I feel like Studios kind of
underestimated how uh actors they can
endure not being employed for a while
though you know actors are kind of
trained to be out of commission to be
out of work for extended periods of time
so this is not new for them whereas the
cash cow machines the amptp they need
that money constantly flowing and
they're thinking about the future at all
times so they need their artists but
these artists they know how to hold out
and I don't think they were prepared for
how long they were willing to hold out
for yeah well you're completely right I
mean struggling actor is a it's a
well-known saying for a specific reason
and even people like Mark Ruffo in the
past he's talked about how he was doing
bus and tables at restaurants and stuff
and it's it's pretty much you go from
paycheck to paycheck until you your
career really takes off but a lot the
time you know you're working minimum
wage jobs to support yourself you'd
never really hear the term struggling
Hollywood studio executive so you know
you can kind of see where the balance is
tip there but I actually did think there
was some positive news this week um so
the ballad of song birds and snakes that
they have reached an agreement where
they can you know Rachel zler Viola
Davis and Peter Dinklage they're they're
clear to promote the film before it
releases this month and it it felt like
Lion gate you know they'd made some
Headway Rachel zler put out a post
talking about how she was so happy they'
managed to do it and then every everyone
probably started disliking it was say a
Rael Z I hate you that seemed like yeah
that seemed like it was a good step in
the right direction we will talk about
the Snow White in just a bit because
they released the first image of that um
but yeah apparently Fran drer she went
to the negotiating table with a
heart-shaped plushy um she said I don't
have to emulate the masculine energy to
be a good leader I can be smart have a
keen ability to see integral flaws in a
business model and put a tiny poche
plush toy between me and Bob AER now I
don't really think she's she's that
smart because to me they're they're not
these business flaws are pretty glaring
and I've been thinking about it the last
week the C I don't even know if the
cinemas are going to still be here if
they don't reach a deal and movies and
this whole thing is delayed to January
and then they have to do it again um
because what like Cinemas have kind of
limped along because of coid they've had
a really bad year this year Disney films
have bombed so much and if you look at
the box office averages if Taylor Swift
hadn't have released that eras to a
thing I don't know if they would have
been you know the year's box offices
would have been really bad and I think
delaying it out you're just putting more
pressure on the cinemas because next
year is going to be so difficult and it
makes me think that the studio execs are
just so shortsighted because they might
even hit a point where they they've got
know where they can release things to I
mean C worlds went into Administration
over here uh there's lots of things
going on and yeah if I was there as soon
as that writers deal got locked down I'd
be like right with made some progress we
need to lock down the actors and get
things going it seems that the box
office for things this year I I I could
be wrong uh and I would I would totally
appreciate comments correcting me all
around seems like the most profitable
things this year and the biggest
surprises were ones that people didn't
truly anticipate would be as massive
hits as they ended up being you know
like we we just you just brought the
aist tour which was kind of this
unexpected thing that just sort of came
out of nowhere uh to be a concert movie
and you know Barbie's one the biggest
movie of the year I think Super Mario is
probably the only one that everyone
thought would be a massive hit and it
ended up being a massive hit Oppenheimer
they're going to be doing a re-release
this weekend I believe I feel like
they're trying to push in on that
billion dollar Mark for it because
they're so close to it and then and then
we had Five Nights at Freddy's as well
which had a day and day release and like
with peacock and theaters and yet it
still did massive numbers and was Blum
House's biggest opener ever so it seems
like the ones that are are doing huge
numbers are the unexpected ones and then
the ones that we had participate to do
well are becoming big flops you know
like Indiana Jones and the Flash and
Guardians did do well quantam Mania
underperformed it mission impossible
underperformed so the ones that where
the studios are investing the most money
into are not doing as well as they hope
where they're throwing like so much
freaking like half a billion dollars at
them and then it's these other films
that are making the kind of money
they're hoping their half a billion
dollar Investments are going to make but
they're also even making more money
because they're made for Less outside of
Barbie which was like made for $100
million or something 12 something like
that uh so yeah this is kind of like a
it's a fascinating time that we are
ultimately living in do you know why the
Lionsgate was able to get the the
interim agreement for Hunger Games I I
don't understand why they were able to
get it no because when I went to check
Rachel Ziggler's post she' blocked me
and all I did was write a thousand
negative comments I'm kidding guys I
haven't ever harassed her I haven't said
anything about we're we're all about
posi year yeah I like I like I like to
say that but probably get Pro more
dislikes for saying I like her than what
I've just said there but no I have no
idea um it's yeah it's I'm glad they can
out you know reach an agreement I know
that films lion gate don't release that
much and I think they've been banking on
The Hunger Games to do well because it
was such a big franchise for them
they've obviously put a lot into this
prequel hoping to catch lightning in a
bottle again I'm guessing that it was
just really important for them to
promote it because like off the top of
my head I can't really think of many
films at lion Gates released this year
Expendable John Wick four John Wick four
maybe
thats John Wick four is Lionsgate
Expendables I believe saw the saw
franchise is is Lions G okay yeah I mean
they' yeah they've done all all right
they've not had it an insane year but
John Wick's obviously done well Hunger
Games was such a massive franchise for
them expend for Bulls we're moving on to
the next subject here which is the box
office this week expend for bulls has
endered its domestic theatrical run with
only $16 million godov damn that is low
holy [__] it's coming off a hundred
million budget what absolutely insane
that is
horrible yeah and you can kind of see
why landcape might be like oh crap we
need to get some stuff in place because
we canot suffer another loss like that
like I can imagine if they had the xend
fo bbls cast out there on the red carpet
you know doing the interviews it's got
quite a big cast to it you know they're
all well-known names um I can imagine it
might have tipped that a bit higher
there wasn't a crazy amount of interest
in the film but for it to be 16 million
off that is it's insane that is a the
part three made 214 million worldwide oh
my God yeah well obviously I mean the
franchise has made enough in the past
where they've Justified making a fourth
film um but yeah for it to be like that
oh not very good this should have been a
huge film this should have been huge
internationally not I I get domestically
but internationally this should have
been huge with the names that they got
yeah I think there was just no buzz
around it I I think that's all it was
and you know I personally believe this
kind of film does need people out there
selling it you know Sylvester Stallone
Jason Stam Dolph lungren Megan for
Andy Garcia you know the guy from The
Raid was in it they could have sold that
I think definitely yeah they could they
could have sold it and but unfortunately
it's just done that and yeah I'm
guessing Lions Gate are like right we
better sort this [__] out because we
actually losing a lot of money at the
moment um so yeah that's in place uh
it's not all bad news at the box office
I'm sure you guys have seen Five Nights
at Freddy's gross and incredible $132
million worldwide with a 20 million
uction budget and for the fact it was
released day and day on streaming that
is absolutely insane and
Universal you know we slag off Universal
because they do lots of copyright claims
and stuff um but they've done some very
smart moves this year and their box
office numbers are absolutely incredible
this year you know Mario alone is it's
one of the biggest films of the year and
very very good for them to get this
we're obviously going to be getting the
Five Nights at Freddy's franchise going
up from the this you know we've we've
had opinions on the movies Greg um and
one of my editors was like what what
score did he give Five Nights at
Freddy's Paul and I was like I'll give
it a five out of 10 and he was like oh
crap um well there's a thread on Reddit
of super fans and they're going after
reviewers and ripping them a new one um
to people who've given them bad scores
and I started sweating going is any way
we could change that five to five out of
five is any way we can remove the 10 but
no so yeah you know I'm quite into
horror movies I'm not massively into the
game franchise but I thought there was
some good parts in it I I think tonally
it was kind of all over the place you
know there was like a comedic thing with
the the anti where it was like all
played for jokes um but then they'd have
more Sinister stuff like his brother
getting kidnapped and tonally you know
there was a sort of an imbalance to it
and I kind of wanted to see all the top
kills those animatronics coming to life
we got we got at some points where the
you know it it's the human drama stuff
Greg you know it is whenever they make
movies about a property like this where
it's you're going there for one thing
they have to add in human drama and you
know sometimes it doesn't it doesn't
connect with everyone and I I felt like
I was one of those people that didn't
fully connect with could appreciate
certain bits but yeah what are your
thoughts uh I I appreciated a lot about
Five Nights at Freddy's and like the
animatronics I thought
did did did the people get to you and is
that why you no no I'm starting off nice
I gave it in my review I said that um I
gave it a six out of 10 and that's a lot
of that is for effort emotionally I'm a
five out of 10 is what I was saying it's
like everything I could appreciate about
what they were able to bring because it
could have been more convoluted like I
did a lot of studying on the lore months
ago and they everything they managed to
infuse in there I'm like surprisedly
didn't feel it was I just I could have
seen an even worse scenario however I
can't say that I overall really like the
movie I didn't find it I had no strong
feelings about it is how I would say I
didn't yeah I I nothing was exciting to
me or it was like
intermittently fun I like the first half
hour way more than anything else
honestly and and to me when I when it
was all said and done I I sort of
thought about it just from a writing
perspective that if they had just sort
of
restructured even if you kept the scene
primarily the same for the most part if
they had restructured it it it probably
could have been more effective I I what
I really liked is when the little girl
Abby goes to meet them and then there's
this kinship and this like silliness and
fun and I thought if they actually came
in with that like earlier before any
kills went down and that way you had a
bit of that methan effect where she is
bonding with with them and then he's
thinking uh you know uh Josh hutson's
going oh this this is the key for me
like being able to bond with my sister
and she likes my job and oh my God then
they start to discover the ghost stuff
and then you do that big kill sequence
later where you're like oh wait a minute
these are not benevolent things these
are malevolent beings in here like
there's something like haunting and
horrible here so then you let the
Sinister thing slowly overcome I think
it's just a little Ian our review is
like 45 minutes long so I really pitched
a very long version of just
restructuring this but I think if they
did have a bit of that methan effect
where you first start off with a sense
of wonder with them and then you go into
the horror I think that would have just
made everything more effective but they
kind of went
hardcore first and foremost the ghost
Supernatural element and then it kind of
made some things a little bit odd I do
think that it was just mainly a a
structural issue that could have
resolved a lot of the common complaints
that I'm hearing and complaints that
I've also shared with the film yeah I
like how you called it Meg Regan because
surely the E is where the three is I
don't know why exra said MC MC yeah but
I liked it call it that from now one did
you hear though uh that the I think they
played it smart like I don't think that
a movie needs to be I don't even think
this needed to be rated R I think you
can do a lot even with the context of
killing the kids and all that stuff
there's a lot of things that feel
Sinister and can feel grizzly in context
alone and just the lore and backstory
that you get with how this all came to
be a lot of that is already like R-rated
in the mind without it needing to be so
visually on screen and and what I found
interesting was like people were
sometimes championing for to be R-rated
but then when you look at the
demographic for the people that showed
up at the theaters a lot of them like
the the first main bracket was ages 18
to 24 but the second main bracket was uh
ages 13 to 17 if I'm not mistaken so
turning it into
PG-13 actually panned out really well
for them like that's how they made so
much of their money was from that
particular demographic and it also goes
to show you that it doesn't matter if
it's releasing on streaming as well
people will show up to the movie
theaters to the clex if there's
something special to be had and I I've
even heard people say that I didn't
really like this movie but being a part
of the crowd that was very much into it
like I watched this just on peacock but
the being but people who said that they
didn't really like it they were part of
the crowd with it they could feel that
energy and it sort of uh they they
adopted that energy with it living
vicariously through them and I feel like
that is something there's still
something kind of special about that
experience for a lot of people and I it
makes sense why a lot of people showed
up for it even though they could have
just watched it know it's pretty cool
well well that's what the films that
have done the best this year have all
have they've been sold as events you
know Avatar Two Sold as an event now one
of the highest Crossing movies of all
time the first did the exact same thing
eras to a barin Heimer they're getting
you to really feel like you have to go
out to the cinema to see stuff whereas
the things that were events like a
Marvel movie or a superhero film they're
not coming with the same cache and
interest because we've just seen it so
much
this feels like something new refreshing
an event and yeah even watching on
streaming you know I can imagine in the
cema that that five might have gone up a
bit higher um and I can imagine it was
the same with the yeah it was the same
with the Eros tour I could imagine you
know you could sit at home and watch
that tour on your TV but I'd imagine
Greg being amongst the people watching
it that's that's why you ended up
delivering a 25 minute review of how you
felt about it with nothing but POS s man
every day and I see the crap I get in
the comments about it but it is all she
just re-released 1989 Taylor's version
go listen
to style is genuinely one of my favorite
songs of all time like genuinely I'm not
even trolling I'm not trying to get the
swifties on board it's not a 4D chess
level plan it genuinely and but I felt
like I had to force myself to like the
new one and it's just it just ain't it
it ain't hitting at the same level you
know what I mean it ain't got the fair
enough James denies you know what I'm
saying but unfortunately um because of
the strikes a lot of things are getting
delayed um so Mission impossi 8 has now
been delayed from June 28th 2024 to May
23d 2025 and it's no longer going to be
titled dead reckoning part two now I'm
guessing this is because the first one
underperformed um and they're kind of
like oh we should just call it Mission
Impossible bread Reckoning or something
just detach it make don't make it a part
two just make people feel like they have
to come and see it because they probably
didn't watch that first one delaying it
by whole yeah is pretty insane but what
this does give our Tommy Tommy Cruz big
fan of the podcast it gives him a bigger
IMAX window so you guys might remember
when he first dropped that mission imp
possible dead reckoning part one couple
of days later I think it was like that
it was meant to release on the Friday
and they managed to push it forward to
the Wednesday and then it was like the
Friday after was bobin Heimer and that
just got all the IMAX screens took that
away so now I think they've got a very a
much better Clear Window for that new
Mission imposs thing where they actually
get the IMAX screens strategically makes
a lot of sense um you want to see a
mission impossible on the biggest screen
possible and it it would be impossible
to not see it in a mission with an
intermission oh sounded really good in
my head but I completely messed it up up
um and there's been another delay with
Snow White that was or originally it was
meant to debut on March 22nd 2024 it's
been pushed back to March 21st
2025 Al so you know yeah I'm devastated
mate um but I bet there's some YouTubers
out there like oh we get an extra year
to make Rachel zler
videos make 400 of
them yes yeah so we got a we got a first
look at it um they've got CGI dwarf in
it you know the the initial reports were
saying that it was mystical creatures
and stuff and I was like well this is
why you don't trust the Daily Mail
because anything they say probably a
load of [__] um and yeah the the CGI
dwarves dwarves in real life they're now
out of business they've done it not to
offend anyone but I'm I know what the
world's like and someone will be
offended somewhere God this this is my
first time I'm seeing this man this is
not yeah so I I actually said I actually
said it looked a bit like a
brazes advert um and I got loads I
suddenly got loads of Disney Stan
accounts like you're a disgusting man
and um people are saying like you have a
porn addiction and stuff I'm like I
don't like where where's this come just
random accounts with like Disney
characters as their profiles I'm like
they've searched me out to say this um
so yeah Disney apparently emphasized the
Vanity Fair that while those early
photos from Snow White set they they
were they they weren't official but they
did have people who were standings for
some cast members um so apparently
they've always wanted to go this route
I'm guessing that is the case because it
takes a hell of a lot to to CGI over
people completely and and you know often
you have to get them to use motion
capture suits and stuff I'm not chilling
for Disney I promise well maybe I am if
you guys like me saying positive things
about them um but yeah it's it's weird
first look you know the CGI dwarves
thing I guess we're going to have to see
um but what are your thoughts Greg
what's your in what's your reaction to
that snow white
picture because because Paul makes notes
before filming and then once in a while
I like to wait till we're actually on
the Pod before I look at something and
so I didn't realize that oh I should
just look up the photo so while you were
introducing this I was typing it and I
found the IGN article and then I was
turning up the brightness because I was
like I don't see them here and then I
turn up the
brightness this is uh kind of disturbing
it's it's there's an
uncanny valley it's creepy it's really
creepy it's unsettling you know I you
know do you remember the end of the
eternals when Pip the troll came out and
it's kind of
like something a bit off here it's it's
it reminds me a lot of that it made me
tense in the shoulders and something
feels offensive even though it's not
offensive I don't know exactly know what
I'm looking at here man this is so odd
uh I don't know whyg them this is so
strange this is so this so
icky yeah I mean there is the debate
around it yeah so Peter Dinklage came
out and said that you know it's
offensive to use dwarves and they can be
more than that they're not just people
to be used in in roles like this and and
he's obviously shown that you know Game
of Thrones absolutely killed it in that
X-Men Days of Future pass great and and
Dinklage is always really really good so
lot of people paid attention to that I
feel Disney reacted to that and that's
why they they went this route um but
then on the other side of that there's
been other dwarf actors who are like
well you know he's up at the top he's
but there's actors like us who are at
the bottom kind of struggling in these
parts help us to get work and and get us
known and there's kind of these two
sides in it I'm not going to wait in the
debate and but Disney have decided in
the end to go with CGI dwarves I guess
we're going to say Obviously um The
Daily wire are doing their own version
of Snow White I'm yeah we'll see how
that turns out but uh lots of lots of
things going on with the CGI dwarves I
have had um I I feel like I've had a
trying to be fair perspective with Snow
White and even when whenever we've
talked about Rachel zler and the and the
comment she makes that keeps getting her
in trouble I I do my best to see the
opposite side this might have pushed me
out of everything that has happened with
this movie this might be
this was it just this like ridiculous
image of I don't know if this is this is
laughable man this is terrible I like I
and I got to see an emotion I and maybe
I'm judging too harshly I'm just giving
my raw honest feeling upon seeing this
initially and I like to be this is what
I'm feeling now and then when it comes
time to see a clip or a trailer I'm
gonna be open-minded because like even
with Little Mermaid I saw some IM like
the little crab um Sebastian I thought
when I first saw like that is that is
disturbing what I'm looking at this is
not this is kind of creepy and then I
watched the movie and it was fine I'm
having a harder time wrapping around
wrapping my head around I
can settle into this it just draws too
much attention it doesn't feel natural
they've done Hobbits you know where
you've taken actors and you manag to
make them little people and so I I but
then to do like these animated CGI
things you're you're making dwarves feel
even more mystical you're making little
people feel more my tile and stuff CU
this is in a weird boat of of a day and
age where people get offended very
easily by by by anything and you got
like I don't know if people do in
general I think on the whole most I
genuinely believe that most people on
the whole have a bit of you know they
don't overreact to things th% they and I
think it's the couple of loud voices
that will just scream and bra stuff
they're the ones who get the attention
obviously um and they're the ones that
stand out and that company's react to
yeah it's it looks a bit weird they
react to social media and stuff and you
know you have you have someone like
Rachel zler they've cast a Latina
actress to play Snow White and it's like
look how Progressive we are and that's
that's all fine and dandy and and from
all accounts or anything I've seen her
and she's a fine actress and and then
they have this where they're like but we
have we have the Seven Dwarves and that
that's offensive to people so how do we
compensate for this and I at this point
I'm like you might as well just not a
major movie if if you if you if you're
this this to me just feels like there's
a dichotomy of of confidence you know
and I don't I don't know how confident
they really are I feel like this just
constantly reeks of more PR damage the
the anything that comes out from their
leading actress of the comment she makes
this IM I don't think they needed to
release this image because they they
don't look real and I think they could
have it's going to be weird watching a
real person interact with things that
are supposed to be real people but they
don't really look anything like it and
yeah I mean got like that remember those
Robert zus animations the like Polar
Express and stuff they kind of look like
that and they I'm assuming they'll look
better in a couple of years obviously uh
but right now
yeah it's just my initial thoughts I'll
be openminded by the time we get a clip
yeah now don't be too harsh on Greg guys
or me this is just one image that we've
seen and it's an initial reaction being
fair keeping an open mind um but yeah
like do you like the image do you do you
personally like this image I don't
really know what I feel it's just like
yeah whatever it's just another Disney
Live Action ripoff that I just feels
being made to make money and I don't
really feel there's you know I don't
think they sat down and like we need to
tell the story of Snow White again I
think they were just like what have we
got that's still
Mak money remade yet what else we got
left we've got snow white but you know
it might be a bit of a PR nightmare
because we've got dwarves in it and
there there's lots of comments about
that yeah but can we CGI the dwarves
yeah sure okay get it made get it made
is
that yeah that's a
thing like obviously we're not in a
position where we can fully speak to it
and uh would just rather not offer a
full opinion because there's there's
going to be people who get offended by
it and there's going to be people who
argue in the opposite direction and I
don't feel like I'm qualified to be
either Camp uh because I've never had to
live through that myself and let's just
watch the debate play out and report it
to you guys at home um so speaking um so
Jonathan Major's next film magazine
dreams that was set to release at the
end of the year that was going to be you
know people were saying it's going to be
big Oscar Contender for him this is
going to be the film that really
catapults him to the Forefront it's been
taken off the Disney slate um as the
legal issues continue to unfold the
Hollywood reporters basically you know
dropped a big report on it they've cited
that the it's the strikes that are the
driving force behind this but this is
the only film that hasn't actually been
given a release date and I do feel like
that reason kind of shows they're going
to see how things play out um if you've
been keeping up on the news on it lots
of back and forth I mean it's
the issue with Twitter at the moment is
anyone can get a Blue Tick and put
something out there that makes it seem
legitimate and there's been things like
the his accuser was supposed to get
arrested um right right the da is
obviously still filing the charges and
but then there was some accounts saying
the charges are being thrown out and
it's Twitter's just literally you can
write whatever you want and someone's
it's G to get spread like wildfire
what's that old saying the a li can a
lie can be halfway around the world
before the truth even has time put it
shoes on something along those lines and
it's basically yeah so it's basically
talking it was predicting Twitter and
how difficult it is but obviously you
know Disney are kind of they've went
full force with Jonathan majes in Loki
season 2 I think the response to that's
genuinely been pretty positive but
they've still got to rest a lot of
things on him and I think they're just
kind of going to see how this goes
because it's so difficult to Mar I mean
we saw how difficult it was to Market
The Flash um and it's going to be a
similar situation with this The Flash
was obviously a comic book movie so it's
it's it's it's probably easier to Market
you know you've got Michael Keaton on
board um Batman you know yeah it's part
of the DC Multiverse whereas magazine
dreams that is going to be solely
resting on Jonathan Major's shoulders so
that you know it's yeah it's going to be
way more difficult to mark it if things
go badly for Jonathan majes in this this
coure case so I can see why they've done
it um you know might not might be
playing the hands a bit but on top of
this they've also given us a bit of an
update on dead pool 3 so you might
remember last week we talked about how
it was getting delayed apparently it's
not the case um as per The Hollywood
Reporter they've been virtually assured
of um getting it back on track and that
it should still hit its release date
personally I don't think it's going to
don't think it's it's going to hit that
anyway um but we we'll see we'll see how
the the strikes go they might fast track
it they might startop working 18 hour
days every single days to get it done H
but yeah we'll see I hope it doesn't hit
that Rel State I think they would become
rushed at this point they're not done
that's ridiculous that's Insanity well
Greg we've all seen how rushing CGI with
Marvel movies has worked out really well
for the for the company I mean no one
complains about the CGI anymore Marvel
you have a so yeah get it out there um
but Disney have kind of got a bit of
backlash this week because South Park
released the pandae special um it was a
one-off special event where you know the
way it was put out there and the way it
really
caught attention was through it what it
was saying about Kathleen Kennedy um
when you watch the episode you know
South Park's very good at doing I I
wouldn't say they both sides things but
they they kind of present both sides of
the argument
um the extremes of it at least and kind
of let the viewer make up their own mind
but they definitely argue they'll never
firmly say like this is wrong and I I
feel like the the storm kind of circled
around Kathleen Kennedy but when you
watch the episode they they go out like
people who complain about welness all
the time and Randy Marsh has a really
interesting Arc in it that isn't really
connected to Disney or Kathleen Kennedy
until like right at the end when they
they're looking for someone to blame and
yeah what did you think of the special
Greg you know what's funny I don't
really watch South Park uh I haven't I
didn't grow up with cable and it was
only on cable and so I just I felt like
left behind by the time I was old enough
to afford cable so I just never caught
up with it but I did decide to watch
this uh just the other night and I
thought it was hilarious man it was so
funny and from the times I've seen South
Park I forget like how much I really do
enjoy it whenever I do sit down and
watch it you know and a in a day we just
brought it up earlier but in a day and
age when online vitrio and easily
offended voices come to the Forefront
it's nice to see something that is no
holds bars offensive you know I really
like I really like the comedy a lot and
and I I thought they had very fair
points I think it's interesting that
South Park often because they're not
saying anything different than anything
we've ever heard you know they're not
really saying anything all that unique
it's just the fact that South Park is
saying it that suddenly it to some it
becomes some I don't really know what
the term would be for it it's almost
prophetic it's the mainstream really
yeah yeah I mean it's in the main like I
wouldn't say South Park's really a
mainstream friendly show but it is
something that's in the mainstream and
so once that picks up attention it kind
of drives the narrative and gives
certain legitimacy to it yeah I thought
it was hilarious as well first of on TV
as well you know it does it's different
than like people doing YouTube videos
bashing on Kathleen Kennedy I I think it
was so funny though and I even like all
the angles about you know the the
handyman and the AI taking over and how
we don't because I I am guilty of that
myself I really related with that like
oh [__] that's right I often don't know
how to do anything and I have to like
call on someone and what it got that if
anything that was thought-provoking to
me it was that the evolution of how AI
will replace because we're always
talking about AI on the internet with
like replacing writers and actors
because we talk about the entertainment
industry but in day-to-day life that's
usually where my conversations go is you
know like people who are in accounting
or whatever or therapists even that
there's that kind of field can Will can
be replaced as well and to think about
what will be the jobs that can
survive when AI is so predominant
what what will be the jobs that are able
to still Thrive what jobs will come up
and I I liked I like that point of view
you know and to me generally it's like
I'm just listening watching South Park
and I'm thinking this is hilarious this
is really funny I'm not watching it I
don't watch South Park for the points
they're going to make and but that out
of anything I watched in that special
that was the most thought-provoking part
and all the stuff about Kathleen Kennedy
was that was funny man just all the
constant like make her gay make her gay
I thought was so funny it it was it was
was really really uh it was really funny
but you you liked it a lot I really did
yeah I really liked it a lot I mean like
I said again you know they they do they
juggle stuff really well even Kathleen
Kennedy at points they they made her
seem like a sympathetic character who's
kind of stuck with getting all this hate
mail all the time and stuff I thought it
was hilarious when she was like I
received 10,000 letters of hate mail a
day and K was like it was 12 12 to
13,000 or something it's just like clear
that clear who it's coming from um but
yeah really really found it funny you
know the aftermath of it we haven't had
the full thing play out I think I bet
there's people at Disney who even find
it funny you know what I mean I think it
was all kind of handled in good heart is
that the right saying but obviously when
when it's like that you know it gains a
lot of publicity but I think you've just
got you know anything you're interested
in you've got to learn to laugh at it as
well and I mean they took shots at stuff
eyes saying that so I think yeah I
thought it was quite funny happy happy
with how it's gone out now Disney it
would keep bashing Disney W sort of
become like a a panda verse special but
Disney right loads of stuff's come out
this week about Loki um so this was
compiled by the streamer now reportedly
about a third of Loki season 1 was
filmed when Eric Martin was approached
by Marvel Studios to be the head writer
of season 2 now from here after Michael
Waldren got the job for Doctor Strange
in the Multiverse of Madness Loki SE
seon two headwriter Eric Martin not only
wrapped up Loki season 1's finale but he
also rewrote much of season one so
apparently Michael Waldren is been well
this is the way that the narrative has
been spun anyway that M Michael Waldren
he's a scumbag and he took Disney's
money and ran away with it and it was
Eric Martin who had to fix Loki and
that's why the finale is so good and
stuff and then he got picked to do
season
two which yeah it's I mean you're always
hearing stuff about this with marvel at
the moment it it does sound like they're
kind of just like winging it the whole
time which is quite funny because there
was a point where it seemed like Marvel
was so planned out that everything was
like little you know I was even
analyzing Iron Man one and talking about
how the first shot is of Tony's hand and
it's holding a a glass of scotch or
something and then the Last Action he
does is snapping his fingers with the
hand and you know it's you started off
with the character with the really
negative thing that was showed he was
selfish and self-centered and stuff like
that and just all a very
self-destructive person just for his own
ends whereas the last thing the
character does is snap those those
fingers on that hand but it's and though
it's you know it's a sacrific to save
everyone and it turns out they're just
winging it the whole time and just
getting people to come in and rewrite
stuff happy
accient yeah but I'm really really
enjoying Loki at the moment still you
know we've sat on it for a couple of
weeks we've obviously
known what's what's coming um I I I
think we talked about it last Tuesday
when we just seen episode four and for
it to still have the impact that it had
I watched itad on Friday and yeah I
thought it was really really good uh
they did release a mid-season trailer
this week that kind of spoiled all the
reveals of episode five which I wish
they hadn't done it I don't think it
would have a massive difference on the
viewership um but yeah we kind of know
where things are going to go now so if
you haven't seen that and don't want to
know don't watch it mate avoid it I've
avoided the trailer myself because you
gave me a heads up that they do spoil a
lot there there's been things coming out
about Marvel in addition too did you
hear about the writer uh the original
writer of Avengers and he came out
happened he oh yeah yeah yeah did it was
in the umcu book more information about
how Josh Josh wait a minute is it Josh
it is Jos J Jos Sweden okay I forgot if
it was Josh or Jos for a second uh but
but Jos Sweden uh he basically got on a
phone with him and was rude it was like
I'm going to rewrite him and he and the
writer thought that Jos Sweden was a
total dick I think that's what he said I
think he said he's a dick and yeah just
more information about how Jos Sweden is
not liked At All by anybody apparently
no one likes the guy and it's kind of
he changed the direction of Marvel I
think so much to this one guy who is now
just like not in the Hollywood Spotlight
at all anymore well you know what's
weird is they had the leftovers which he
he made and I'm sure they had the second
half of that completely filmed and
finished and they just didn't release it
because of all the controversy around
them but there is a bit in that book
where they talk about that quite a lot
and they said like the guy was fighting
for credit and Jos Weeden basically shut
down that he had any involvement with it
and stuff and said how bad his original
script was and how much he had to fix it
and that's horrible yeah not not nice
not nice um but Daredevils also got new
show Runners now obviously we had the
big controversy where um it wasn't a
controversy I I respect Marvel for doing
it and being like Oh we need to start
again H but they've made some changes
behind the scenes the head writers Chris
order and Matt Corman they were let go
from the series and now Dario Scot aay
will serve as show on out with directors
Justin Benson and Aaron mohead taking
over for any re-shoot and the remainder
of the episodes so yeah they've worked
on lots of things such as Jack Ryan
Netflix's version of The Punisher and
John berol will obviously be coming in
the new show as Frank Castle um
apparently it's going to get more of a
serialized tone to it that's closer to
the grittier feel of the Netflix
original they have come out and said
that it's not going to be connected to
that Netflix Universe though some things
might cross over from it but yeah it's
it sounds like you know they they've
went to the people who work with Netflix
and said I don't know why they didn't do
that in the first place you know we did
kind of think it might be to do with
contracts but sound sounds like it's
it's a good step in the right direction
it's not nice when people get fired from
stuff if they're halfway through it even
things like Batgirl my heart went out to
those directors who NE are never going
to get to see their work probably but it
sounds like Marvel at least stn
knowledging stuff needs to change I mean
Justin Benson and Aaron I think are
great directors I love what they've been
doing with Loki I love the darkness that
Loki has I thought what they did the
episodes they did on moonnight I thought
were fantastic as well do they know how
to do psychological provoking Darkness
you know it's not just dark and an
aesthetic or Surface like it's under
it's the feeling underneath that I think
they capture very
well and I'm curious though what the
choreographers are going to be for
Daredevil that's something we haven't
really discussed in The Ether of it all
you know I remember when when Daredevil
first came out and often what people
have cited when they look back on those
first three seasons Beyond just the
Fantastic storytelling that they have
you know they've had the obviously the
famous One shots in every season every
one of those Seasons had one take that
was great you know right down to the
third season with the prison the prison
riot scene prison escape is insane like
I don't even know how they filmed that
some of the things that are timed in it
they happen so naturally and it'll be
like 10 minutes in at the scene you'd be
like how have you timed this so
perfectly to the point where it's all
worked out yeah and it's insane you
can't even really see the cuts in that
stuff and that was not even you know
Charlie Cox in a mask so a lot of it had
to have been him whereas when I watch
the hallway the hallway Fighter the
season 21 you can kind of see where I
hit it cut for the season two one might
be and those wipes but then you have
moments where even in the first season
hallway which feels like a genuine one
take you can kind of predict where they
might have switched out Charlie Cox with
a stun double whereas in the season 3
one I'm like I'm not sure if they ever
switched him out with a stunt double in
this one because looks like it's just
him the entire time anyway even the ones
that weren't one takes they had amazing
choreography in them you know uh and I I
think in the MCU the best choreography
has been like winter soldier shangi and
the Daredevil the fight scenes and I and
I think uh in She-Hulk I I like Matt
Murdoch uh in shehulk I like I thought
the way they I don't I don't want that
tone for the Daredevil born again show
but I liked I thought he fit well for
the She-Hulk episode but when they had
action scenes definitely didn't capture
the action that we love of Daredevil and
I'm really curious to see cuz they have
moonnight they they worked on moonnight
and while I the moonnight action was
pretty good for the most part it
definitely didn't climb to the heights
of even Daredevil and I'd say the same
thing for the Punisher coming in The
Punisher has a very different kind of
choreography and I love the violence and
I love the choreography and Punisher and
I'm very curious what they're going to
bring over for fight choreography here
because I think that's a that's a very
important element story first and
foremost obviously uh however the the
fight scenes are I think just as an
integral trademark to what made shows
like Daredevil and Punisher stand out as
very strong prevailing TV shows in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe while we had
the big screen stuff going on was the
the small screen choreography outdid
most of the big screen choreography you
know honorable honorable mention for
good Marvel MCU scenes the guardian
volume three cardo bit you know at the
end when they go and they one shot all
that that's an absolutely fantastic
scene really well done by James gun
probably his PS D resistance in my
opinion um but yeah just make Daredevil
good please like this you know if if
they if they gave me all the list of the
upcoming projects and were like all of
these are going to be mid except one and
you get to choose which one it is I'd go
those 12 how many episodes is it however
many it is please just make I think it
was like 18 originally they were going
to do and then they split the season
into whatever I'm I'm got no idea guys
I'm sure you're screaming at your phone
right now thinking this guy's a compete
[__] but yeah please make Daredevil
born again good please please more than
anything and yeah get that get that
hallway fight down I think that's the
thing with Daredevil with it coming over
from another Studio at Netflix you you
need to at least match it or better it
and if you don't then people are going
to complain and be like this isn't as
good as what it was on Netflix now
speaking of declines Greg tickets for
the hash Marvels right have reportedly
earned the lowest pre-sales for an MC
movie in the postco era and you can tell
you can tell from the marketing that
stuff's going by now guys I'm going to
warn you skip ahead to the next section
because there's been lots of leaks
coming out about things they added in
the film if you don't want to know go on
the Echo trailer bit so what so there's
been a a clip released today that talks
about the next thing coming the next big
event and for some reason Greg they they
hold a bit on the the X in the word next
the the rest of the letters fade out and
then there's the X in there they give a
little bit of attention of that and from
what I've heard Greg there's going to be
a post-credit scene that's been added to
the end of the movie
um that has beast from the X-Men in it
now apparently wait like be beast from
like Fox X-Men or or beast from yeah
this the first time I'm hearing this
yeah well oh really have I ruined it for
you apparently I'm sorry it's all CGI
but they've got uh
must
Le yeah well I think they have I I
personally think you know this when this
report went out last week I'm sure I
said something on Twitter about how I
guarantee the in quotation marks leaks
and the cameos will leak in the next
week or so um obviously we know from the
marketing certain Asgardian going to be
in because we see the by Frost Bridge
guessing that's going to be Thor and
maybe his daughter love and but yeah
apparently Kelsey grar is back as Beast
CGI at in the post that would Daniel rpk
was talking because I remember a couple
weeks ago on Twitter he was saying like
I'm hearing a character
something along the lines of a character
that did great but was in a shitty movie
is coming back is that what he might
been referring to okay yeah so so Daniel
rk's patreon actually put out the whole
Beast thing um and yeah it's kind of
email because I'm actually pledged to
the patr must miss that yeah um and he
also yeah so I feel like it's going to I
feel like it's going to be one of those
things where after the first weekend I
guarantee we get a TV spot with him in
it it was the same I'm sure with no way
home where once that first weekend was
out the way they dropped Andrew Garfield
and um Toby Maguire in now it might come
earlier because like we said the ticket
sales are low and I feel like they're
really starting to to panic with this a
bit and they also released a clip online
yesterday um what did you did you see
that clip I did see the clip what did
you think of it yeah think it I thought
there were some cool to start off with
some positives I thought there were some
cool shots that primarily dealt with the
way they handle like certain Focus
lenses and and like when they would do
the I forget the name of the kind of
shots when they like zooming in but
pulling out at the same time there's
like a famous One In Jaws when he first
sees the shark attack Roy shider and
that he had a lot of cool little angles
there um the choreography was fine uh
it's it's more it's tonally what I
expected it to be I light up when I see
like I I love Kamala Khan I love the
little thing where she like pops over to
Nick Fury and she looks over at him and
she go hi but yeah it's not exactly the
thing I'm I'm clamping at the bit to go
see I'm not I I'm going to see it I
already reserved my advanced screening
to go see it so I'm looking forward to
it but the the clip didn't do anything
to really excite me the song was a weird
Choice maybe it'll work better in the
context of the movie uh but I as of now
the the song is what was that song do
you know what that song was I don't know
what that no idea no that kind of does
take me out of films a lot when they use
like pop songs over the top of things I
think Guardians of the Galaxy used it
really well and then Marvel probably saw
the success of that or even in the MCU
book they were talking about how
difficult it was for James gun to get
actual songs used in the movie because
they used to just scoring films and I I
personally prefer scores for films I
think that works better um and it was
just the music that kind of mess it up
for me actually really did like the
scene I think man balani as well she
kills it as Miss Marvel absolutely kills
it she does such a good job with it I
actually have a friend who went to one
of the events the other day and he got
to see the first 22 minutes of it and he
said it was really good so that's made
me a bit more excited you know it is 22
minutes I mean if you'd shown me the
first 22 minutes of quom mania I'm sure
I'd be like this is one of the best MCU
movies I've ever seen so you kind of
have to you know see how how it plays
out and the second how many movies do
you go to Greg where you've heard it's
terrible before going to see it and then
you'll you'll go and you'll be watching
the First Act and be like this is I
don't know what all the critics are
talking about this is the best movie
I've ever seen then two hours my
reaction to Five Nights at Freddy in the
first half hour going I literally say in
my video like what's everyone talking
about this is totally fun and then and
then it starts to progress and I'm like
oh I'm starting to see some issues so
yeah I think it's going to be I think
it'll be fun though I feel like it'll be
fun there are like little nitpick things
that pop up in my Noggin of this was the
woman who took on Thanos why are these
guys opposing a challenge but from what
I take it in the fight scene she's
resisting using her powers at full force
because it'll cause her to like
transport places like switch in and out
with Kamala KH so she yeah to resist a
little bit okay yeah that was a part of
it I still feel like she would be super
string I don't know it it looks it looks
fine to me and I and I feel like
I'm not I I wasn't the biggest fan of uh
Brie Larson's performance in Captain
Marvel and I think a lot of that came
because I've seen I've seen Bri Larson a
lot of things where I really loved her
work in it from dramas to comedies you
know like it's Scott Pilgrim 21 Jump
Street people forget that she's actually
in those films and so I've seen her a
lot of things where I think she could do
a wonderful job and and I I think with
this direction already there you could
kind of see it in the Miss Marvel post
credit scene which was a clip from the
Marvels and then even in this clip I
think they've done a little bit
more Reinventing and I don't know if the
right words Reinventing but just
allowing her to feel more natural now
that Carol ders has evolved and come
into her own a little bit more I looking
forward to seeing what Brie Larsson
brings different this time as opposed to
what the direction was for her character
in the first movie you know like I
the only time a character really gets re
like Mark ruffalo's been reinvented a
couple of times obviously Thor's been
reinvented
significantly and some sometimes to
Greater to lesser effect you know
depends and I think Carol
damers this could be one that could win
over a lot I know people have issues
with brie Loris in the person however I
think Carol ders the character they
might be more liked this time around and
that's what I'm very curious to see with
her yeah I was speaking to my friend
about this the other day and I was
saying it's just something about that
first movie she's not she doesn't feel
like a a charismatic MCU character she's
very kind of dialed back quite serious
you know she has her little jokes and
stuff and I was actually saying I think
tonely that would have worked really
well in the DC euu um but amongst all
the other Marvel characters it kind of
just feels I don't know and you can tell
though they like endgame the way she
acts in that there are the same
character traits but you
the just the the thing that she does
with Thanos when he headbutts her and
stuff and she's just stood there kind of
it feels like a really good character
moment and and I'm hoping that they kind
of lean into that a bit more they the wh
if Episode actually that was quite good
where she fought Thor quite enjoyed that
so do you not remember no one just came
back to me party th fragment in my mind
yeah party Thor yeah yeah yeah so see
I've got to remember all crap Greg every
single MC thing that's happened because
if I don't remember it then someone's
going to write a comment going you son
of a [__] you didn't remember that one
thing H yeah so I'm hoping they lean in
with that you know it's a 90 minutes
long I don't think it's going to
massively do well I think what'll
probably happen is it'll do okay
there'll be people that ride for it
they'll say you know what it's really
good and then it'll kind of yeah it'll
kind of just be another Marvel movie
rather than being that the big thing I'm
guessing the post credit scenes going to
be the big talk but post credit scenes
don't sell movies yeah post credit
scenes don't sell movies which you've
seen time and time again recently yeah
um so yeah onto our last no not our last
topic onto another topic involving one
so the Echo trailer is apparently
releasing this week meant to be
releasing Friday yes Greg I I can't
understand this Marvel marketing because
I I'm not I do with brilliant Paul it's
brilliant I'm not covering it and it's
not because I hate people it's it's
literally I don't have the time to do it
because this Friday Invincible episode
one debut season 2 episode one o seen it
crazy um gen V finale low
key and the Echo trailer and we don't
brilliant point we don't have Loki
screeners anymore so we have to they're
going to be beginning later our videos
than they have been
yeah yeah and you brought up absolutely
brilliant point yesterday when I was
talking to you about it do you want to
say what it is or should I I honestly
don't remember what my point was but I'm
excited to remember what what was the
point your point was that they're
marketing Echo Loki and the Marvels at
the same time and it's kind of dividing
your attention yes I have I still have
no idea why the Marvels and Loki finale
are releasing on the same day and it's
actually at the point where it's a
genuine anxiety nightmare for me because
I'm thinking I could do like a really in
I could wake up watch Loki do a really
in-depth breakdown about the Multiverse
and where things are going and how it's
all kind of branching off and what's
going to happen next time right and then
I could put make about a 30 minute video
out where I based off the Loki finale I
I come up with loads and amazing
theories and then I go see the Marvels
like two hours later and everything in
that video is debunked now in opposite
to that I could go see the Marvels first
right put the video out on that make it
same thing then watch loky it's I get
everything wrong and it's it's also the
reason it's stupid to release things on
the same day is because we're living a
world of trending topics you know that
we only get a certain amount of things
that show up on the feed you're dividing
your attention and fan base away from
both products by doing this because oh
you know if the Marvels doesn't Trend
it's going to look like a failure but it
might be because Loki and all the things
that happened in the finale they're
what's eating up the trending feed and
yeah it's just I just don't get why
they've done it and then amongst all
this they're also going Echo comes out
in January we better Market it now no
save that till like December or
something what why you doing it now this
is a really busy week so don't
understand what's happening with that
corre it has an opposite effect of
anticipation you know it's like they
instead of getting you to focus on
what's out now they get you to think
about what's coming out in the future
and I think that strategy does not work
anymore for Marvel yeah it out it wears
you out it loses the impact and the
significance of what is currently out
and the importance of watching said
property that is currently present for
the public to see you know and and I
think especially if they do dump this
Echo trailer in the midst of everything
it's just going to get lost like this is
not what people will be interested in
right now if it's going to feel lesser
than what's currently like Marvel's is
already feeling less exciting than Loki
Ekko is going to feel significantly less
exciting than Marvel's so you want to
wait when we don't really have a Marvel
thing going so we could have something
to look forward to that is a Marvel
thing instead of just let it I think
maybe the strategy is we're putting
Marvel stuff out there so now is the
time to promote our future Marvel thing
I don't think that works anymore though
I think it's pretty apparent that it
that it doesn't work that way it doesn't
work well like that it's they're trying
to feed it like some weird algorithm
machine but that's not the way audience
interest works I don't think they've
known how to re they still have not
figured out how to readjust to having
multiple episodes of television and
movies at the same time you know because
like you're asking for six week
commitment for Loki and keep the attent
like just keep our attention there so
like the idea they're going to release
Marvels the same day as the finale is
that's so stupid to me it is stupid
because don't you want people at home
watching Loki instead of going to the
theaters that night to watch marveles I
think it's a really bad idea aide I
think it's a terrible idea and you
obviously also have Invincible as well
you know you're competing with that
Invincible is brilliant and we will talk
about more in just a bit but yeah it's
just I don't get this strategy I think
they kind of felt like everyone was
anything marel they could put it out
there and people are going to go see it
but they haven't really changed that
mindset yet and in order for people to
be excited about something they almost
need to miss it have the anticipation
and they just get hit with another
Marvel thing like I'm I'm like I I can't
physically cover all this stuff so I'm
just not going to it's it's either I I
work like a 24-hour day doing all this
thing and kill myself to do it and I
just think yeah I'm just not going to do
it I'm I'm not going to knock up my
mental health to cover it I'm sure there
will be channels out there that do it
but you know we're quite a small team we
we don't have writers and people doing
our scripts for us so it's a bit more
difficult got for us Chad gbt exists
Paul yeah I should just do Echo trailer
breakdown drop it in chat
gbt yeah yeah so I I do kind of feel
like H it's just such a weird move to
drop it then and you you're basically it
was the same when they dropped um Ms
Marvel and Obi-Wan on the same day at
the same time stupid it's like what you
there's other days in the week and just
in the same way there's like there's
other weeks of the yeah mate you don't
need to drop Loki finale and the Marvels
on the same day just take it easy didn't
they premere Loki and Ahsoka the same
week Atoka finale and Loki Premiere the
same week and there were so many
comments that people going I didn't
realize Loki was coming out this week
yeah that was another nightmare to cover
and I remember Hawkeye and no way home
were in the same week last year because
people are like oh what if the finale of
Hawkeye ties into no way home um and
yeah it's just kind of I I don't really
necess neily get why they're doing it
because we like we our whole business is
built on people watching our stuff um
but we we have to cover things that are
out there and I don't I'm sure I speak
for you as well Greg we hate releasing
more than one video a day because we
know for a fact that our subscribers
aren't going to have the chance to watch
them both there's no way um and it what
it's going to do is decrease views
you're doing more work to get it out
there and you're getting less of the the
views from it because people just don't
have enough time in the day you know
where where I'm dropping like 30 minute
breakdowns and stuff if I drop three in
a day or something people aren't going
to have 90 minutes to sit and watch me
drone on about stuff and if if they do I
feel sorry for them we we would never do
this and I feel like we have and that's
because we've done it so many times in
the past where we realize it doesn't
work and it just splits your audience
and yeah hopefully this is the last time
but it kind of this kind of forces us to
uh release m I already stress out about
like when do i p like your genv videos
are doing like phenomenally better than
mine at the same time I'm like when do I
publish my genv video wonder even even
this week like we I'll be able we'll be
able to get our gen V videos out early
but at the same time like I'm already in
contemplation of and maybe you are too
of do I publish gen V when Loki is
playing you know on Disney plus but will
people watch our genv video is out do I
wait to hold off because our Loki video
is going to come out much later than it
has been coming out and then we got
Invincible the next day so what is the
publ schedule gonna be like and it is a
it is a thing of like you want to create
momentum and and I think that's what
Marvel is going for is they think
they're creating
momentum I think you're just kind of
diverting attention and and not getting
the the most out of your viewer that you
can
which is I think it's counterproductive
is what they're doing I think
that's now another big comment that
always comes up when we talk about this
stuff guarantee is that things are very
expensive right now and people just
don't have the money to go to the cinema
which I totally you know understand it
times are so difficult at the moment um
and if the choic is between the loky
finale at home or sh shelling out
however much to go and see the Marvels
people might just be like oh well you
know I'm getting you know we have Marvel
at home you know what I mean that's
that's basically the meme if the kids
are like I want to go see the Marvels
it's like we've got Marvel at home got
Loki on TV so yeah it's uh it's just a
very strange strategy and I think it
would have been smart to you know break
these projects up throughout the A and
not just drop them all in one day is
crazy and so I'm just not excited for
Echo at all because I'm just thinking
we've got so many other things out that
I'm that are the Here and Now whereas
that's months away and I don't have to
care about it at the moment um but one
thing I do have to care about is
invincible so got to see the first four
episodes I'm not going to be doing
theories in the breakdowns or I might be
doing them and getting them 100% right
every time but Lov them absolutely loved
them did a big uh big read through of
the comics again just to get you know
caught
killed it they killed it they they
nailed so much stuff and took it in so
many different interesting directions um
we're not going to spoil it obviously
because it's not out yet but the things
I do with the characters and the way
they kind of develop them from Beyond
the
page it's it's it's really really
incredible and there's so many things
that I I wasn't expecting it to be like
um and the the aftermath and way they
treat Mark it's different from the
comics slightly and but they just give
them much more more depth and really
just even Debbie Debbie gets such a much
better role than what she had in the
comics and yeah Blown Away by it um
probably up there as being one of the
best Series this year and
Amazon like I don't know who they have
well I do know who they have working
over there but they're on the next level
when it comes to superhero stuff gen VY
that could have easily just been a
run-of-the-mill you know superhero
spin-off show that was is n doing
anything crazy just about college kids
CW whatever gen V is incredible as
well I I have a question for you
Paul and it totally left my mind as that
slipped out of my mouth what my question
was I was like ask Paul this question as
I was saying it I was going what
happened to the question it has left my
brain no further questions no further
questionss it was a good one oh yes I
remember my question my question is that
do you is do you do you
believe that perhaps Marvel is feeling a
bit I don't know if the right word is
threatened or con it could be a bit of
concern because you know Marvel's
obviously been in the PG-13 camp and
there's a lot of touting the fact that
they're going to be doing you know
Deadpool will maintain its R rating
do you think there is a
concern with because they have
Invincible coming out and they're
supposed to release Echo trailer that
day Loki they moved and to release
earlier that was probably just due to
Ahsoka sure ahoka performing well at
that
time at the same time as like they were
aware gen V was coming out as well and
gen V and Invincible are very hard are
superhero properties that are also very
much beloved
do you think there's a bit of
a obviously the fan base is bigger for
Marvel do you think there's a bit of a
competitive concern though over the fact
that they like the R-rated ones are
actually doing
better yeah I do actually and it skips
my mind but there was a DC project this
year where something happened in it
released and you could tell Marvel
dropped something the exact same day to
just kind of suck the air out the room a
bit yeah what was that I remember that
it was definitely something yeah I
remember I remember we talked about that
yeah oh that we were saying like it it
was basically Marvel coming in and
Swinging their dick yeah like I'm it
might have been the um Ben Affleck
Aquaman 2 thing thing and something
along those lines where it was like DC
did an announcement where and then you
know marvel just came in and was like
time to swing my dick yeah might have
been like the deadevil Born Again
announcement or something um I remember
that yeah I remember us having that
conversation um they've just released an
official clip B Loki season 2 what
happened looks like they're spoiling the
whole thing next um
yeah why what is the [__] point what
a brilliant Cliffhanger don't release
anything such a you want nothing more
than to find out like what are they
going to do obviously Loki's alive but
like let's find out why and what's going
on I don't understand it's so stupid so
dumb there's no need there's no
need I feel like they could have taken a
week off with Loki you know what I mean
they might have even been able to put
like the Marvels in between that week
you know have Loki end with a Victor
timely thing drop the Marvels in
everyone's like oh my God I'm gonna have
to go see the Marvels now because it
might explain what's happened with Loki
they don't tell you um and then that
happens they do the same thing they did
with infinity war and end game um but
yeah Rob another one robers of anticip
ation it's so it's so annoying like this
is the this is the problem of what we're
talking about is just let us Ponder for
a week let us let us be like I got to
tune in to find out what happens not
really [__] to to spoil it Ah that's so
frustrating that's so stupid so stupid
to
me well that's we try and be positive
Greg but we always go down this path of
what the people doing I feel like Kevin
FY you should just ring me up and go
Paul what do you think when you do you
think I should release the Marvels and
Loki finale on the same day and I just
go no and hang up yeah no be smart to
your also to to your point about
Invincible I've only seen the first
episode and and I love the first season
I absolutely love the first season I
intend just because of some sometimes
depending on what the property is I'll
like actually go and dissect the comics
before because I do like the reaction
commentary review [__] so like last of
us like I really absorb the games before
watching it and then for invincible I
like to go in blind to it so I don't
actually know the comics of invincible
and so everything's always a big
surprise to me when I'm watching it but
from a narrative standpoint just from
the first episode as I rewatched the
finale I rewatched the whole season over
the past couple weeks and I finished the
finale then the next day I watched uh
episode one and I was pleasantly
surprised with the direction they took
just from the first episode because it
might not be the because I have such a
brilliant Cliffhanger with the first one
and I'm not going to say any sport story
details at all but with the Cliffhanger
of the first one one might be led to
believe like oh we're just going to gear
up for pedal to the metal type of
craziness VTR might's coming in you know
like some some [__] like that after what
they set up and I appreciated the
grieving
melancholic
tone that they took because it there are
some big Stakes things that they're
introducing yet it still feels extremely
character focused for and and a lot of
Great Character setups but it feels like
a
natural transition or the na natural
Next Step from what happened because
there's only like a it's only takes
place a month after the finale and
I was surprised by oh this is a
different this is different it feels
more serious with more polished
animation but I loved it I and I've only
seen the first episode I really love the
direction they decided to take with just
this one like a this this so character
focused yet it's still exciting to me
you know well I was talking to a good
friend of the show Simon riopa
showrunner of invincible writer of
episode one executive producer wow big
guy also did the boy dibal he was like
Paul so but I was saying to him it kind
of reminds me of like I didn't pick this
up from the comics but you know my
parents got divorced and you can kind
of I see that almost in Mark which I
never saw in the comics you know his
dad's just left went somewhere else he
doesn't know and he's having to deal
with his mother you know with the
depression with that and it you could
just feel the sadness coming out from it
but it's so well structured and
characteriz and incredible and it's got
the action in it as well you know it's
got the high moments it's got yeah the
low moments it's got the characters
everything just works about it and go
read the comic Greg you you will
genuinely really enjoy it's such a good
run it's a great kind of it the boys is
a good parody of stuff um like superhero
the Justice League you know Batman it's
a good parody of it Invincible has those
same archetypes but but it's very
sincere and very character driven and
the way they go with the characters oh
you get so attached to them and it
doesn't necessarily feel
like it's it's almost like a soap opera
in that not every issue is like a big
thing it's just kind of you're just
following the daily lives of these
people and it goes I mean I've got the
omnibuses behind me there if you can see
them uh but yeah you just work through
it and just see this guy's life from
basically the day becomes a superhero up
to day that everything's all gravy or is
it no spoilers on the channel of heavy
spoilers but yeah brilliant can't wait
to see it you know gen finale I don't
know if we're actually allowed to talk
about that because last the the boys
finale I actually put out a tweet saying
loved it and then the pr hit me up like
we appreciate the kind words but can you
delete that tweet because you're not
actually allowed to review the finale um
so I don't know if I'm allowed to talk
about the J finale but lots of things to
look forward to on Friday when they just
throwing everything out there and saying
good luck
guys make good luck making video guys I
have I have one question about
Invincible before we wrap this up when
it when it comes to the comics is it
very AC is the is the show very accurate
to it because that was the reason why I
put off on reading it was because I
didn't I heard it was so I mean I've
only heard it like from one person that
it was really accurate so I was like oh
well then if I read it then I'm not
going to enjoy the surprises or turns
that it takes when I'm watching the show
so
yeah so yeah so it is accurate but they
switch things about and you know this
the order the the way I I'm actually
really surprised at how they managed to
reorder things and still keep it
consistent because there's some things
that you would think I don't know why
they've put it at this point of the
story because it needs this to happen
beforehand but they they find a way to
work around it sure just read it Greg
otherwise you're going to be you're
going to be sitting waiting for about 10
years probably before the actual story
fully wraps yeah I could read up to
where this this season ends right like I
could do that yeah I think it's about
issue 40 where this season ends damn
okay from what I've seen I could get
like 40 issues I probably can't say that
yeah but um yeah it's I'm probably
saying too much now but it's a if you
buy the first Omni bus it's pretty much
all in that okay cool cool thanks
appreciate it you're a good man yeah
brilliant well thanks a lot guys um as
always we're on Spotify Amazon music if
you're on the go we always appreciate
the thumbs up there'll never be a time
where I say I don't appreciate that
thumbs up and there'll never be a time
well there probably will be a time when
I say I don't appreciate that comment
and it's it's probably the one you're
writing right now saying your podcast is
absolutely [__] I don't know why I keep
listening to it and but thanks for
coming back to us again sorry to Del
late we've got lives guys got to got to
live our lives but it might be a nice
surprise for you today but this this one
guy who constantly talks about how he
listens to us when he's in his forklift
truck and I'm hoping that the guy had
some entertainment yesterday when he
missed us and I'm hoping he he's working
today as well but shout out to you guy
you know who you are don't drop it don't
drop it don't drop it yeah we love you
guys and thanks so much for all your
support yeah you really help us do this
podcast because if it was just me
talking to Greg I don't think I'd do it
because I hate hate him um but yeah
thanks thanks so much for sticking with
us love you so much and uh we'll see you
next time thanks a lot mate thanks guys
any final words um no I I just want to
say thank you guys for being awesome
everyone here is awesome I appreciate it
and let's hope Rachel zegler is able to
rebound yeah unblock me Rachel if you're
listening yeah I didn't mean those
10,000 posts a day